in this video what i want to talk to you
about is how we two and a half x the
lifetime value of our physical products
business by adding in recurring revenue
for most businesses small or large
adding in recurring revenue is going to
be the single greatest way to increase
your enterprise value and so i've been
doing a really deep dive on this uh just
thinking through it because i'm trying
to create a checklist for my own
portfolio companies um and so i just
figured i would share it with you and so
going through this deep dive the first
thing i want to do is kind of challenge
one of the original thoughts that i
think comes up all the time is i don't
have recurring revenue i'm not a
recurring revenue business etc and i
think that that is binary thinking which
is either our recurring revenue business
or you are not a recurring revenue
business when in reality is to what
extent are you recurring in business how
recurring is your business is a better
question
and so what um after after thinking
about it for almost a few hours this
morning i was writing down in my lovely
ipad here my ideas around recurring
revenue and uh there are eight c's
because i'm trying to make this you know
memorable for myself too that you can
implement to make your recurring revenue
more sticky and so just as a quick side
note or tangent on this before we dive
in it doesn't matter what type of
business you're in you're there's always
a an extent to which you can become a
more recurring revenue business so a
typical example that i'll get in this
instance is someone's like well i'm in
real estate you know there's nothing
recurring about my business which is so
silly it just means that you have a very
limited time horizon right and the
question is uh one if you're a realtor
you absolutely have recurring revenue
business because you want to have the
lifetime value of the customer and every
single house they buy and sell right
right even if you were selling houses
for example who else is serving for
recurring revenue it's not the house the
bank is consistently giving you loan
after loan after loan what you're really
buying is a mortgage right not the house
it's secured by the house you're getting
a loan for money which is secured
against the house it's not actually the
house itself so to the bank and the real
estate agent and the escrow company
those are the companies that are
generating recurring revenue from this
quote single transaction right but
they're hoping that you would continue
to visit them over and over and over
again i just wanted to make that shift
for anyone if you're in the car repair
business right like and you have an auto
shop of course you want to have
recurring revenue every business owner
long enough time horizon is recurring if
done properly right and you can either
choose to make it more recurring or less
recurring and so the purpose of this
video is to show you how to increase the
stickiness increase the recurring nature
of the services and products and or
access that you sell within your company
all right and i'm doing this within
again my own portfolio companies and so
i'm doing this because i want to share
these frameworks with you so the first
of these and this may be you know maybe
the most obvious is consumption right
the goal uh to increase the stickiness
of recurring revenue is to increase the
consumption and you can think about this
from a physical standpoint which you can
see physical here i'll see if i have a
little error i know it's a little small
that's what she said deal with it but uh
consumption right the goal is like if we
can get someone to eat the food that
we're making every single month they're
going to want to buy more of it if it is
good to the same degree netflix has a
recurring revenue business and it's not
like they have contracts or anything
like that but it is purely based on
consumption you want to continue to
consume
the things that they put out and so you
continue to pay right
and so spotify again you want to
continue to
consume the music and so you pay right
now the cool thing is is that
if we're still thinking along this
binary versus continuum thinking process
it is not uh you know do i get my people
to consume the product but it is how
well do i get people to consume the
product right and so for each of these
eight cs that i'm about to go through
don't think is it a check box of yes or
no
but instead to what extent do i do this
and the idea is not that you want to
have all eight i mean it would be
magical if you had all eight but if you
can easily think through each of these
uh c's um as ways that you can bolster
or make your business more recurring uh
than it was before and each of these
individuals you can do better or worse
so you have you have continuums within
continuums and that sounds complex and
that's why we like to use the
psychological binary or shorthand of yes
or no but reality is not nearly as
simple all right so the first of these
is how can we get someone to increase
the consumption of our product and
services and so that creates that means
going through you know creating better
onboarding experiences improving the
actual value of the product itself
making it more addictive in nature etc
right so somebody wants to continue to
consume it the second of these
is collateral so is there um
is there any way that we can secure our
uh recurring revenue against something
else all right so i'll give you two
examples in the physical world if you go
to storage they have your physical goods
they have your stuff right and so you
must continue to pay because they have
your stuff right it's a secured uh
continuity stream a different way in the
digital world dropbox is storage they
just have your files and they have your
stuff google drive is storage right and
there's different types of collateral so
the idea for us as entrepreneurs is how
else can we create collateral either
physical or digital um that that makes
that we can secure against this
continuity so people want to continue to
stay and pay a different version of this
would be like a crm right crm has all of
your contacts and all of those uh you
know all the contacts all their
information etc that they are now
holding and they're holding i don't want
to say hostage but they are relatively
holding hostage from you so that you
continue to stay right so that is a
second way that we can increase the
stickiness of the continuity that we are
making the next is cost of switching all
right and so this is a lot this has
somewhat to do with psychology which you
have the time cost sorry the time uh
cost of switching which is like it might
be very arduous or lots of effort uh to
switch over providers of x y and z right
um and or uh it might cost you a lot of
money to do that and you can even
further increase this psychological bias
in your favor by increasing the sunk
cost fallacy on your prospect so a way
of doing this for example would be if i
were selling a hundred dollar a month
continuity if i told someone that they
had to spend five thousand dollars one
time to begin working with me and then
it was 100 a month the likely that they
would cancel would be significantly
lower i talked about this briefly inside
the 100 million offers book which is the
bigger the head the longer the tail if
you have a really big upfront it makes
it much easier to drive the recurring on
the back end and so the stickier it will
be and so you can make that in terms of
fees you can make that in terms of time
money investment basically the harder is
to get into something the the
psychological bias against the harder it
will be to get out and so the cost of
switching will increase the stickiness
of the recurring revenue that you have
for physical products or services the
next is choice all right so the idea
here is the lack of choices so if i had
uh if i were the only only you know xyz
service provider on an island i may have
a lot of stickiness to my business
because there are no competitors now
that may be short-lived if someone else
sees what i am doing and then sees the
opportunity right um but the idea you
know patents are a way to decrease
the choice that uh consumers have for
alternatives right if you're the only
one who owes this patent for this
medical drug then they have to continue
to buy from you over and over again you
can argue the ethics around it but
that's not the point of this channel the
point of this channel is simply just
showing the economics behind the
business model so if there are ways that
we can
decrease the alternatives that someone
can have because we have a unique
competitive process or a trade secret
that we have that allows us to do
something differently or better than
everyone else and fundamentally this is
the point of differentiation in and of
itself is to decrease the alternative to
decrease the choices someone has if you
were the absolute best at xyz there will
no there might not be a choice of anyone
else who can do what you can do this is
also the reason that niching down is so
valuable for many businesses especially
if they're starting out because there
might not be anyone else who will have
their unique combination of skills
resources etc to provide the value in
the way that they do right and so our
idea to create a stickier business to
have more recurring customers to have
more recurring revenue is to decrease
the other alternatives right either
through directly with patents uh you
know indirectly by having no one else on
the island or by having some sort of
competitive advantage that we have that
no one else has right trade secrets of
some kind the fourth is control of the
money flow this was one that i added
near the end because i was thinking
through it i was like what else is
really sticky what else makes recurring
revenue sticky and one of the ways is
candidly a lack of transparency and what
i mean by that is you know uh uber you
know for example they're gonna take
their fee before they pay you know the
government
takes their fee which is your taxes if
you're an employee before you pay which
is why most employees don't have nearly
the same gripe with taxes as most
business owners because the business
owners see the checks that are coming
out every month whereas many of the
employees do not they just see the end
result of the money i'm not saying that
no employees don't have issues with
taxes that's not my point here i'm just
saying that if we're talking about to
what extent or a degree on a continuum
the more overt the charges are rather
than covert uh or before someone can see
it or without them seeing it then the
the stickier it is because they are less
noticing of the fee or charge right and
again my argument here is not the ethics
behind this it's simply that this is
something that the more a business or
recurring revenue stream has this nature
embedded within it then the stickier it
will be in general all right because
again all of these are continuums within
the larger continuum of
how sticky or how recurring is your
business not whether your business is
recurring or not and so we want to take
more and more steps along each of these
continuum to overall bolster bolster the
recurring revenue nature of our business
all right
the next one uh is cause all right and
what i mean by that is are people
aligned with the cause uh that we are
that we are we are we are standing for
so churches have recurring revenue
people pay 10 they tithe towards the
church right and so if people are
aligned with the cause then they will
continue to pay because they're getting
value because they associate their
identity with that cause all right uh
this is why building movements within
businesses are so valuable because then
we can we can act and function far more
like a church can in in the fact that
people will associate their identities
with the cause and continue to pay
because of who they are
and because of what they believe that
the cause represents charity there are
some people who continue to give over
and over again even though the benefit
that they're getting right because there
is still a product of charity the
product is the feeling that people get
when they when they pay because they
feel good about themselves and so if we
have this nature within if we can embed
this nature within our recurring revenue
stream then we will make it stickier
right people donate to political parties
every single year that is a recurring uh
commitment that many people do people
continue to frequent the same brands
because they believe the brand stands
for something that they too believe in
right and so this is kind of the more
amorphous or vague part of it but still
very very real in terms of how you can
create stickier recurring revenue all
right the next one is community all
right and this one i was really really
hesitant because i almost i almost put
it in with cause but it felt different
enough that i felt like i should pull it
out but
people continue to pay for things if
they feel like they're they're becoming
a part of a community and they would
have to sacrifice their identity so
you'll notice between cause and
community um they're both related to uh
the identity that someone has which is
they're gonna be
it's commitment and consistency they're
going to they're going to continue to be
consistent with what they believe to be
their identity because people don't like
to be inconsistent with who they are and
so if they believe they identify as
being a part of a community then they
will continue to want to pay uh for that
community the next one is contracts that
are enforceable so by and large i'm not
the biggest fan of contracts i mean
obviously we lawyer up and we have all
of our our legal resources and that's a
necessary you know part of doing
business um but uh
having contracts in and of themselves
can increase the stickiness i'll give
you a simple example so if i said i have
a 2 000 a month continuity whatever
right and you can just pay as you go
right that will probably net me if i
were to have two things that were equal
in value that i'm providing right two
thousand dollars a month someone sign up
let's say for a six month contract at
two thousand dollars a month or what i
would say a twelve thousand dollar
program that has six payments of two
thousand dollars now if i know that my
recurring revenue stream as a
month-to-month version uh only has let's
say four months of stick if i can sell
this as a twelve thousand dollar package
the likely that i get that extra one or
two months is high and so i'm saying
just if two products and services are
identical but we package them
differently the one that is sold with a
contract against a against a total value
will likely be stickier because people
are committing to a certain period of
time and so if we have contracts that
are enforced that is just one way of
making a contract enforceable another
way of making contract enforceable and
this is somewhat a degree of collateral
which is someone has a their credit
worthy right they can ding their credit
if uh if they if they breach their
contract right so you do have some sort
of collateral which is kind of the
nature of making contract sticky is that
you want to have some collateral but i
felt that this was different enough
especially with the example of you know
charging twelve thousand dollars for uh
for for six times two versus a month a
month of two thousand dollars a month
you may end up getting more people to
pay and stay longer simply by
positioning it as a six month agreement
that then goes month to month after the
six months right and so just by making
that tiny change in terms of how we're
positioning we might be able to increase
our ltv or probably lifetime gross
profit by two or three x simply by
making that one change all right which
is a massive improvement for a business
and so just another way that you can
think of how can i make my recurring
revenue stickier how can i make my
business more recurring i'll do a quick
recap for you the eight c's of recurring
revenue and our goal here is to think of
this as a as a continuum checklist which
is if i'm looking at my service how can
i make it how can i how can i get people
to consume more of it right how can i
make it more valuable how can i make it
easier to use how can i make it so
people want to use this over and over
and over again number one number two how
can i increase the collateral that they
have when they do business with me so
that so that they they can't leave
because i have something that is secured
against it right secured against their
recurring fee that's coming over and
over again how can i increase the cost
of switching so how difficult in time
money or sunk cost or perceived time or
perceived money can i make it so people
do not want to switch next how can i
enter a marketplace where there's fewer
choices or how can i increase my
competitive advantage by making uh
trademarks i p trade secrets or
continuing to assemble products so that
no one else can deliver what i can
deliver this is kind of the competitive
mode that warren buffett talks about the
controlling of the money flow is there a
way that we can figure out how to get
paid first or get paid off the top or
somehow
tie it so that
our fees are less
overt again i'm not talking about the
ethics behind it i'm simply talking
about the efficaciousness
right the efficacy
of this uh way of doing and increasing
the stickiness of it next how can we
create a cause that we are aligned with
so people can identify with what we are
which is they buy shoes from us not just
for the shoes but for the cause that
they identify with in addition to right
the the classic um tom shoes example how
can we increase the community not like
yes i have a community check we've
already got that taken care of but how
many more ways can we strengthen and tie
the community together so that people
feel like they're leaving a community
not a business which is much harder and
then in so doing make our revenue
stickier and then finally how can we
make contracts that are enforceable part
of that is going to be selling to better
or higher quality prospects but also
again um having something
that that we can collateralize the
contract against and even simply uh
making people agree to a certain amount
people are going to in general be more
consistent with the commitment that they
make
if they say that they're going to stay
for for six months you will have more
people stay for six months if they at
least say they're going to stay for six
months even if not all of them do you'll
still have more people stay than would
otherwise do that now that may be harder
on the sale and this is part of
businesses balancing those things i hope
this made sense for you in terms of how
i think through recurring revenue in the
business how we can increase the
recurring nature of our business because
again this is not the binary of i ever
recurring versus a non-recurring
business it is to what extent is my
business recurring and to what extent am
i checking off each of these boxes that
we just went over so those are the eight
c's of recurring nature uh recurring
revenue as i know them put any other
ones that you can think of if you think
that there's something totally different
or if you think there's examples that
that that tie into any of these c's
throw them in there i think it'll be a
good lively discussion um if you found
this valuable my name is alex from rosie
i own acquisition.com we have a
portfolio of companies that's 85 million
a year and i have nothing to sell you so
if you like this hit the subscribe
button and i'll see you guys in the next
video bye